das ist eine weitere atemberaubende
sensation rund ein jahr nachdem das
erste foto eines schwarzen lochs
gelangen gibt es nun ein zweites
spektakuläres bild es zeigt materie die
dem schwarzen loch nur knapp entkommt
und zwar jets und was uns noch
vielleicht schon bald erwartet ein bild
des supermassereichen schwarzen loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße dort gibt es
noch konkrete schwierigkeiten das zu
berechtigt zum science und fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses neue bild ist kaum weniger
spektakulär als die aufnahme des
schwarzen lochs in der galaxie m87 das
dem event horizon teleskop kurz ehc erst
im vergangenen jahr gelungen war nun
liefert das ehc schon wieder ab und zwar
gibt es jetzt ein foto von den
sogenannten jets in der fachsprache wird
damit ein phänomen bezeichnet das durch
die gravitationskräfte eines schwarzen
lochs ausgelöst wird schon seit langer
zeit wissen fachleute dass diese jets
existieren und es gibt auch schon einige
bilder auf denen zu erkennen ist wie
materie aus dem kern einer galaxie
heraus spricht doch die neuen aufnahmen
sind wirklich eine absolute sensation
denn damit kommen wir dem entstehungs
punkt solcher jets tatsächlich so nah
wie noch nie zuvor
kurz um verständnis um ein schwarzes
loch rotiert die sogenannte
akkretionsscheibe um dessen zentrum dort
sammelt sich materie bevor sie in das
zentrum eines schwarzen loch stürzt wir
kennen das alle von den simulationen
schwarzer löcher
diese akkretionsscheibe ist extrem heiß
und strahlt und ein teil der materie in
der akkretionsscheibe wird nicht vom
schwarzen loch aufgesogen stattdessen
wird sie in form zweier starker
gebündelter plasma strahlen ins all
hinaus geschleudert und zwar senkrecht
zur scheibe und mit nahezu
lichtgeschwindigkeit genau dabei handelt
es sich also um die sogenannten jets
dazu eduardo ross vom bonner
max-planck-institut für radioastronomie
der an der aktuellen studie beteiligt
war
die gravitations energie das aus der
akkretionsscheibe auf die zentral quelle
einfließenden materials wird dank
starker magnetfelder in der jet basis in
elektromagnetische wellen umgewandelt
die in einem weiten wellenlängenbereich
abgestrahlt werden von kurzwelligen
röntgen und uv licht über sichtbares
licht bis hin zu radiowellen immer
wieder beobachtet man sogar strahlungs
ausbrüche von harter extrem kurz
gammastrahlung die aktuellen aufnahmen
stammen von dem casa mit der bezeichnung
1379 der unfassbare fünf milliarden
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist somit
liegt dieses himmelsobjekt noch einmal
fast 100 mal weiter entfernt als das
schwarze loch in der galaxie m87 dessen
aufnahme dem event horizon teleskop im
vergangenen jahr gelungen ist bei kasan
handelt es sich um die heißen und hellen
zentren von sehr weit entfernten
galaxien meistens und sie gehören mit zu
den leuchtkräftigen himmelsobjekten
überhaupt ein quasi 1379 leuchtet im
durchschnitt so hell wie viele billionen
sonnen zusammen in ihrer mitte vermuten
astronomie team supermassive schwarze
löcher die als energiequelle dienen bei
dem quartal 3 279 handelt es sich wohl
um ein schwarzes loch dessen masse
achtung eine milliarde mal so groß sein
dürfte wie die masse der sonne das
forschungsteam des eventreisen teleskops
hat sich ein trick zunutze gemacht um an
die spektakulären bilder zu gelangen und
zwar nutzten die fachleute insgesamt
acht teleskope an verschiedenen orten
der erde
diese werden mit hilfe einer speziellen
technik mit der bezeichnung very long
baseline interferometrie miteinander
verbunden zusammen besitzen die
teleskope damit über eine auffang fläche
die etwa so groß ist wie die erde selbst
dabei werden radiowellen aufgefangen so
dass es möglich wird auch sehr weit
entfernte himmelskörper extrem straff
darzustellen und zwar so scharf als
würde man von berlin oder hamburg aus
eine zeitung in new york lesen oder
anders gesagt mit hilfe des event
horizon teleskops könnte man eine
apfelsine auf dem mond erkennen
die erreichte bildschärfe zeigt somit
details die kleiner als ein halbes
lichter sind zu erkennen ist unter
anderem wie sich der jet innerhalb
weniger tage verändert und krümmt das
setzt auf äußerst krasse
geschwindigkeiten schließen die neuen
aufnahmen ermöglichen es erstmals die
wechselwirkung zwischen jet und scheibe
zu beobachten
die ergebnisse offenbaren dass sie jetzt
alles andere als gradlinig verlaufen
doch eine erklärung für diese erkenntnis
haben die forschenden noch nicht dazu
der radioastronomie thomas kriechbaum
aus bonn wir wissen noch nicht warum der
jet sich an seinem fuß punkt so stark
kommt vielleicht wird das jet plasma
aufgrund der magnetfelder auf gekrümmte
bahn gezwungen es könnte aber auch ein
schockwellen phänomen seien dadurch dass
die aufnahmen an mehreren
aufeinanderfolgenden
gemacht wurden sind außerdem auch
zeitliche veränderungen ersichtlich
möglicherweise führt der einfall von
materie auf die rotierende
akkretionsscheibe dazu ebenso könnte der
ausstoß von material in form eines jets
für die veränderung sorgen darüber sind
auch die fachleute selbst überrascht
denn solch ein szenario kannte man
bislang nur aus simulationsrechnungen
die ergebnisse legen nahe dass sich die
abgebildete materie offensichtlich mit
20 facher lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen
müsste nicht jedoch laut
relativitätstheorie das ist ja unmöglich
ja der zufolge die tatsächliche
geschwindigkeit dank kleiner sein müsste
als die lichtgeschwindigkeit dennoch
steht fest dass das tempo ultra hoch ist
die bilder offenbaren zu nehmen auch zum
ersten mal strukturen die quer zur
fahrtrichtung verlaufen die fachleute
vermuten dass es sich hierbei um teile
der akkretionsscheibe handelt dazu yeom
kim vom max planck institut für
radioastronomie der an der studie
beteiligt war jedes mal wenn ein neues
fenster zur erforschung des universums
geöffnet wird kommt etwas neues dabei
heraus wir haben nur erwartet mit
unserer superscharfen aufnahme dem
bereich abzubilden in dem der jet
geformt was wir zusätzlich beobachten
konnten ist die senkrechte struktur das
ist wie wenn man eine matrjoschka puppe
nach der anderen öffnet und man glaubt
zu wissen was in der nächsten ist und in
der kleinsten findet sich eine
überraschung diese erkenntnisse sind
übrigens nur der anfang denn die bislang
genutzten daten stammen alle noch aus
der ersten beobachtungs und von vor drei
jahren 2017
jetzt steht ein weiteres spektakuläres
ziel auf dem plan und zwar ein bild des
zentralen supermassereichen schwarzen
loch in der milchstraße sagittarius
stern doch sein flackern stellt sich
hier als große herausforderung dazu
anton zensus der direktor des max planck
instituts für radioastronomie im
vergangenen jahr konnten wir der welt
das erste bild vom schatten eines
schwarzen lochs vorstellen nun sehen wir
unerwartete veränderungen in der form
des jets von 1379 und wir sind noch
längst nicht am ziel angekommen wir
arbeiten weiterhin an den daten von
sagittarius stern der central quelle
unserer milchstraße und von anderen
aktiven wie wir im letzten jahr schon
betont haben das ist erst der anfang
zudem wollen auch noch die daten aus dem
jahr 2018 ausgewertet werden im
kommenden jahr soll das netzwerk der
teleskope sogar auf 11 erweitert werden
die sensation ist da das erste
bild eines schwarzen lochs anklicken
anschauen und krieg zum science fiction
abonnieren falls das noch nicht getan
haben sollte und vielen dank an alle die
uns über kanal mitgliedschaften fördern
in diesen zeiten hilft uns dass er bis
dann bleibt dran